live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions it's the Dave Ramsey show
where dead is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the BMW as the status symbol of
choice I am Dave Ramsey your host this
is your show we invite your calls
toll-free a triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight a
two five five two two five you can get
in right now if you dial well have you
heard have you been watching the news
the world is coming to an end it's over
the UK left the EU and those four little
initials are causing the entire sky to
fall have you heard Chicken Little
get your helmet it's all over life as we
know it on the planet is over we're done
ah well it was good while it lasted
this whole American thing it's it's all
over because UK left the Union it's just
we're just gonna have to wrap it up now
you guys pack up your stuff it was fun I
hope you like living in caves and eating
berries hunting wild game our lives are
over
haven't you heard yeah
what you haven't had the news on the
world is coming to an end it's official
it's been announced stock market is
crashing it's dying it's plummeting it's
going down so fast there aren't
adjectives to cover it have you heard
that's all I mean the vocal cords on the
broadcaster's are standing out for neck
muscles are standing out as they talk
about it it's over they've all called me
today want me to come on TV tonight and
talk about it I will yawn I'll be on CNN
I guess tonight or one of them or two of
them or whatever it's fine I'll happy to
do it I don't mind it's just same song
different verse you guys I mean really
when are you going to quit letting your
emotions and your belief system be
formed
by Fox and CNN really if you sit and
watch the news all day long you're going
to be in a rubber room people their job
is to scare the crap out of you
including your local weather forecaster
who breaks in every time it rains I was
a kid you know when they broke in to
network programming for a local weather
announcement never never I'm still here
I actually heard a local weather
forecaster the other day say there's a
funnel cloud in your area if you don't
have a cellar get a football helmet and
sit in your bathtub you're kidding me
that really get really come out of this
person is my unbelievable you're kidding
me
Dave you don't think tornadoes are
serious yeah but so is trying to drive
home this afternoon and traffic around
here either one I'm gonna get you killed
I'm really not gonna sit up and worry
about this stuff 24/7 so let me help you
with this I've talked to like 16 people
in the business this week people have
been selling and dealing with stocks and
mutual funds for 25 and 30 years got
socks older than most of you here's what
they're all telling me and I just wasn't
I just asked them if I just what I
thought and I said is this right and
they all said yeah that's right three
weeks from today let's just let's just
round up okay let's say the first of
August you will not even remember that
the UK left the EU EU that the United
Kingdom pulled out of the European Union
three weeks from today you won't even
remember it you'll be on to the next
crisis because your local news media and
your national news media and your cable
news media will be on to the next crisis
they'll be trying to figure out what
flips Trump's hair next right and
they're going to move on and the stock
market by the way will be back
you're on it'll be back do you really
think listen anytime that there's this
much change in anything like like
Britain there's that much change
in the UK the UK people freaked out but
they voted for it because they were sick
of unfettered borders they were sick of
their porous borders because of the EU
rules they were sick of outside
influences tell them how to run their
country they were sick of the horrible
management of the euro they were sick of
it and they decided they wanted their
sovereignty back they didn't want to be
part of a conglomerate anymore that was
telling them everything to do they were
sick of it people just like to be
managing their own lives countries tend
to like to manage their own selves and
so the British people voted to leave I
think it's a good thing philosophically
are there downsides yeah there's
downsides but I like me I like people
who take control of their own destiny I
take control of my destiny I try to get
you to take control of your destiny
every day so but when that happens if
something that's been in place for what
thirty years and forty years and fifty
years different parts of the EU and
their influence over Britain there's a
whole lot of people that are walking
around over there that have never known
Britain aside of being a part of the EU
in other words if you're 30 40 or 50
years old or less you don't have any
memory of parts of that and so guess
what people are freaking out every time
there's change people freak out every
time there's change at work my company
just got bought Oh God
why would it be better that your company
got bought maybe it was being run by a
bunch of jerks maybe you'll have more
opportunity now that I got bought but we
don't think that anytime there's change
we freaked out Oh Church changes a
pastor to a new pastor oh I don't like
change I may leave I can't stand change
people don't like change
guess what stock market doesn't like
change because it's managed by the
psychology of people people like you and
me that made two investments and when we
see something we don't like change we
freaked out and then we freaked out
because other people are freaking out
and then a whole bunch of people freaked
out because more people were freaking
out and there's this huge freakout but
there's absolutely nothing change
about the United States economy as a
result and matter of fact there's very
little changed about the British economy
because they're not leaving for two
years it's not like you think that
suddenly all of those companies were
that with that much less profitable two
days later no they're not that much less
profitable so why their stock go down
that much freak out no logical
mathematical explanation for it stock
market is partly driven by greed and
freakout speculation and fear because
it's driven by psychology so what's the
more the story the mall story is the
world's not coming to an end as a matter
of fact the world may be better as this
unfolds you didn't lose your retirement
your retirement went down a little bit
in fact you've retirements down about
what it was probably maybe May first
well maybe maybe maybe March 1st now so
whatever he gained since March first you
probably give back but it'll be back
you'll be ok just don't sell just keep
investing don't sell and don't let all
this hype and melodrama that has become
the broadcast culture drive your
investing decisions it'll make you look
stupid don't do it this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
you